Le 1er février 2012, j’ai pris un avion
de Toronto à Pékin.
Question.
Par où pensez-vous que l’avion est passé
? Par l’Europe à l’est, ou par le Pacifique
à l’ouest ?
Quand je suis monté dans l’avion, je n’en
savais rien.
C’est en regardant les écrans de bord et
mon hublot que j’ai découvert la réponse.
L’avion Toronto-Pékin passe par le pôle
Nord.
Et oui.
J’ai survolé le pôle nord !
Off.
Mais ça, ça peut paraître très surprenant.
Surtout quand on regarde la trajectoire que
l’on a suivi sur une carte.
Et bien…
notre carte favorite, celle que l’on trouve
dans les livres d’Histoire et sur Google
Map, la carte dite de Mercator, est fausse.
Off.
Voilà à quoi ressemblent le Groënland et
l’Afrique sur la carte Mercator.
Voyons quelles sont leurs vraies tailles relatives.
Est-ce que c’est ça ? Non.
Est-ce que c’est ça ? Oui.
Le Groënland est vraiment si petit.
Ou plutôt, l’Afrique est vraiment si géante.
La superficie de l’Europe tout entière
rentrerait non pas une fois, non pas deux
fois, mais trois fois dans celle de l’Afrique
!
Ça peut paraître anecdotique, mais ce genre
de carte a le mauvais goût de flatter les
égaux des pays du Nord en les agrandissant.
Littéralement.
Les cartes ne sont pas juste une représentation
du monde.
Elles sont devenues notre représentation
du monde !
Off.
Et ça, l’historien Arno Peters l’avait
bien compris.
Peters proposa donc une alternative à la
carte Mercator, qui, elle, respectait les
tailles des pays.
Mais le grand public rejeta cette carte dite
de Gall-Peters.
Sous prétexte qu’elle était « moche ».
Mais pourquoi la Gall-Peters est-elle moche
?
Off.
Prenons un autre carte.
Vous voyez ce que c’est ? Oui.
C’est juste la Mercator, mais avec le Nord
en bas.
Elle n’est absolument pas plus fausse que
le Mercator.
Pourtant, elle est étrange, voire désagréable…
Du coup, si vous n’aimez pas cette carte-là,
c’est parce qu’on n’y est pas habitué.
Se pourrait-il qu’il en soit ainsi pour
la Gall-Peters aussi ? Oui.
Sans doute un peu.
Mais pas uniquement.
Off.
La Gall-Peters a aussi le gros dégaut de
mal représenter les formes des pays.
Quand on zoome sur une partie de la carte,
on voit que les formes des pays sont très
différents de ce que les satellites voient.
On dit que la Gall-Peters n’est pas conforme.
En particulier, les angles dans la Gall-Peters
diffèrent des vrais angles sur Terre.
Off.
À l’inverse, la Mercator a le bon goût
d’être conforme, ce qui rend le zoome de
Google Map si agréable.
Cependant, la Mercator n’est pas la seule
carte conforme.
Off.
Sur son site web, Jason Davies liste un grand
nombre de cartes, dont beaucoup sont conformes.
Ces cartes sont fascinantes.
Après tout, chaque carte est une merveille
mathématique.
D’ailleurs, au 18ème siècle, la cartographie
est devenue l’affaire de matheux, comme
Lambert, Lagrange et Euler.
Mieux encore, au 19ème siècle, Gauss, Cauchy
et Riemann ont su relier la cartographie à
l’étude des fonctions à variables complexes.
Ces fonctions jouent notamment un rôle central
dans l’hypothèse de Riemann, dont El Jj
parle dans une vidéo récente.
Du coup, on peut se demander si on ne peut
pas faire mieux que la Mercator…
Off.
Il y a eu des tentatives assez originales,
comme la carte de Lambert, celle de Goode,
ou celle de Waterman.
Mais ces cartes conformes ne sont en fait
pas des représentations entièrement justes…
Existerait-il une carte vraiment parfaite
?
Et bien non.
Gauss prouvera en 1827 l’un des plus beaux
théorèmes de la géométrie, le theorema
egregium.
Off.
Ce théorème dit que la géométrie d’une
surface peut être déterminée à partir
uniquement de mesures à l’intérieur de
cette surface, par exemple en additionnant
les angles d’un triangle.
En particulier, sur la Terre, la somme des
angles d’un triangle est supérieure à
180°.
Du coup, Une carte parfaite de la Terre devrait
aussi avoir des triangles dont la somme des
angles est 180°.
Du coup, toute carte de la Terre doit avoir
des angles faux ou des droites pas droites.
Or on a dit que les angles sur la Mercator
étaient justes.
Les droites de la Terre n’y sont donc pas
droites, ce qui explique pourquoi l’avion
Toronto-Pékin avait une trajectoire si arrondie
sur la Mercator, alors qu’il semblait voler
tout droit…
Off.
À l’inverse les droites sur la Mercator
ne sont pas des lignes droites sur la Terre.
Prenez par exemple un parallèle très proche
du pôle Nord.
Ce parallèle fait en fait le tour du pôle
Nord.
Donc si on cherchait vraiment à suivre cette
trajectoire sur Terre, on devrait faire un
petit cercle, ce qui ne correspond pas du
tout à aller droit.
Mais donc, pourquoi la Mercator est-elle devenue
si omniprésente ? Pour comprendre question,
il nous faut faire un peu d’Histoire.
Off.
À l’époque de Gérard Mercator, au 16ème
siècle, l’Europe partait à la conquête
du monde avec sa flotte de voiliers.
Or, pour naviguer, les marins utilisaient
la boussole, le compas et la Mercator.
Ils alignaient ainsi le Nord de la boussole
avec le Nord de la Mercator, puis reportaient
l’angle de leur déplacement par rapport
au Nord sur la carte.
Cette construction n’est valable qu’avec
la Mercator, car seule la Mercator est conforme
avec le Nord toujours en haut !
Mais si on y réfléchit, ça, ça veut aussi
dire que les voiliers de l’époque ne voyageait
pas en ligne droite.
Pour aller de l’Europe à l’Amérique
du Nord, il prenait plein ouest.
Or, on a dit que suivre un tel parallèle
n’est pas une ligne droite.
En fait, les navigateurs de l’époque devaient
constamment dévier légèrement leur trajectoire
vers la droite, pour rester le long du parallèle.
Leurs bateaux ne naviguaient pas droit !
Off.
Et ça, ça dit quelque chose qu’il va être
super important à comprendre, surtout quand
on parlera de la relativité générale.
Quand on se balade sur la Terre, il existe
des trajectoire en ligne droite, que l’on
appelle parfois géodésique.
Ces lignes droites, sur Terre ou ailleurs,
correspondent à prendre une direction et
garder la direction de mouvement constante.
En particulier, j’entends souvent dire que
les lignes droites sont des trajectoires qui
minimisent, ou maximisent, une distance.
C’est tout à fait vrai.
Mais je pense que ce n’est pas du tout la
définition « naturelle » ou « intuitive
» des lignes droites.
Une ligne droite, c’est surtout une trajectoire
que l’on trace, quand on se déplace avec
une direction constante.
Off.
En géométrie intrinsèque, ça correspond
à dire que l’on va se déplacer dans une
direction, et que notre direction de mouvement
va être transportée dans nos position futures.
Cette idée correspond vraiment à « garder
la direction de mouvement constante », mais
où la constance de la direction de mouvement
est dictée par notre espace environnant.
Mathématiquement, la manière dont une direction
de mouvement se transporte d’un bout d’espace
à l’autre est ce que l’on appelle le
transport parallèle.
En géométrie extrinsèque, par exemple sur
la surface d’une sphère vue à l’intérieur
de notre espace de dimension 3, la direction
de mouvement à un endroit donnée nous indique
notre position future, mais elle se projette
aussi à nouveau sur la sphère pour nous
dire quelle sera notre direction de mouvement
future.
Autrement dit, le transport parallèle en
géométrie extrinsèque nous est donné par
la projection de la direction de mouvement
sur les bouts d’espace voisins.
Off.
Ainsi, sur Terre, deux directions de mouvement
initialement parallèles vont finir par se
rapprocher puis par intersecter.
En fait, il n’y a pas de droites parallèles
sur Terre, il n’y a que des directions de
mouvement qui sont “localement parallèles”.
Les droites de la Terre s’intersectent toujours
à des endroits antipodaux.
Et surtout, si les droites ont l’air de
vouloir s’intersecter, ce n’est absolument
pas parce qu’il y a une force mystérieuse
qui les attire.
Si elles ont l’air de vouloir s’intersecter,
c’est uniquement à cause de la géométrie
de l’espace dans lequel elles évoluent.
Et ça, c’est une idée qui va vraiment
séduire un certain Albert Einstein…